Intro...yay
Depression can be difficult to explain
Like any mental illness it feels different for every person
But we at Psych2Go on to bring people together to will share their experience and maybe even help others out
So we asked our readers and viewers
Who has experienced depression and how would you explain what it feels like to others?
Here we've made a list of 16 analogies for Depression
Disclaimers some submissions have been edited for length and/or Clarity number one
It's like you have weights built into your arms and legs
They're heavy and they make any basic activity feel like I'm dragging around dumbbells that are too much for me number, two
It's like you're screaming and pain
But there's no sound coming out of you number three my depression feels like a black hole
But you're not in the black hole you are the black hole your mind
Is. It sucks in anything that might make you feel emotion, and it turns it into darkness
nothingness
number four
Depression feels like I'm in black and white and the rest of the world is in color
I can't be a part of it. No matter how much I might want to I don't belong
Number five it's like a prison without bars. You're trapped by an invisible force preventing you from being happy
Number six, it's like the waves of the ocean
Sometimes the waves recede and you see the beautiful sand with the pretty sea shells
Soon the tide will come and swallow all that beauty up and drag it away from you
What helped me fight that feeling is knowing that the waves will recede again?
number seven for
Me, it's like a heavy mist
Sometimes it's far enough away, but at other times it presses me down
it can enter your body and lungs brain stomach and limbs everything feels sick as
if you haven't had fresh air in a while, and it's
exhausting and frustrating
Number eight to me. It's completely like the dementors from Harry Potter's Jk
Rowling's representation of that struggle was on point
number nine the fog that lingers in the early morning, sky
Never completely fading always present and blurring your vision
Number ten it feels like being in the middle of a large body of water without seeing shores
Something tugs at your leg, and you struggle to keep your head above the surface you gasp and struggle
But it's exhausting and tiring and frightening at the same time
sometimes you truly doubt if you'll ever make it out of there if the thing tugging on your leg will ever let go
number 11
To me it feels like being snowed in by an avalanche you're disoriented
And you don't know which way is up so you dig tirelessly in the wrong direction while being starved of oxygen
Everything around you is cold and looks the same
Number 12 it's a weight on your chest holding you down
No matter what you do. It stays there, and it spreads throughout your body and everything else takes more effort than ever
Number thirteen it's like trying to run underwater. It's exhausting and annoying and it gets you nowhere
number Fourteen
For me Depression was an old TV that lost its signal all
colorful images turned into noisy strange black and white mess of Spots
All of the good things I'd lost and all the bad things I've still got
Sounds turned into buzzing noises and my favorite things everything I liked turned invisible
number 15
It's like all of the Joy was sucked from my body
In my chest is nothing only emptiness, and I'm bearing the weight of the world on my shoulders
Everything that I loved makes no sense anymore
The only thing I want to do is crawl into the darkest corner of my room curl up and cry even though
I'm ill crying won't help is just feeling nothing at all
number 16
The feeling of being chained around your neck connected to all of your fears and getting tugged around ruthlessly until you choke
And that's our list
maybe you can use one of these to explain your problems to the people in your
surroundings who have trouble understanding what you're going through if
You've experienced depression and have your own analogy then feel free to share in the comments below